red leather you're recording yeah
a ratchet attached to two dragon will
come and beat his drum at a quarter to
two good
you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things comedy network this
is a
uh
centennial bicentennial american history
podcast each week
i dave anthony read a story from the
celebration of america's 200 years to uh
my co-host gareth reynolds best country
on earth who has no idea what the topic
is going to be about
it's about america i thank the lord and
how great america
always been the thing about it is dave
it ain't ever gonna not be good
because why and no matter what happens
we keep saying that america
uh i was talking with someone over the
weekend about how uh
remember how they used to like you know
tvs changed in our lifetime so much but
when it used to just be whatever a few
channels
it would end
with the singing of proud to be an
american yeah
and like a bald eagle and flagship flags
yeah so be like at one like tv would
just be like all right we're done for
the night
it's the best country
yeah
that night
be like oh man
reagan's doing it
clinton's my pal yeah that was crazy
that was uh that went on for a long time
long time and everyone and we just allow
it it's just these these multiple
patriotic oddities that we're born into
that until you at least have some sort
of
mental awakening or you do the podcast
the dollop you're like wait why did we
do that people are like are we doing
that people from other countries think
we're absolutely batshit crazy with all
the national anthem before games
and nationally you know just driving on
the street and having flags everywhere
like everyone's like what are you guys
but before games before games is bizarre
you know like it's just like we can
separate these two what's going on with
you it's coming off oh my lord your
fingers naked wow uh
if you want to do your dumb little dates
what do you mean talk about how you and
i are dating um
sorry one second everybody okay five
four a dragon will come and beat his
drum a ratcha to tata okay everybody
it's me gareth reynolds co-host of the
dollop podcast listen this coming
weekend
i will be this is going to be the dave
in protest this turned us back to me but
dave i do have a logistical question for
you this will be the
which episode this will be from
in two two from now bud
okay great thanks buddy he did
communicate everybody so we're back on a
cool page dave gave me a thumbs up um i
will be at the denver improv friday
november 26th and friday november 27th i
will be in appleton wisconsin thursday
december 2nd december 4th at the skyline
comedy club i'll be in chicago illinois
december 5th at the den theater i will
be in indianapolis at the white rabbit
on december 17th i will be at fort wayne
indiana at the tiger room on december
18th and then i'll be in somerville
massachusetts december 19th at the
crystal ballroom and then new years
bring it in with your buddy gary no no
no it's gareth screw you dave
i will be at the comedy club of kansas
city
a great place i'll be there december 2
30th through january 1st let's
turn the page on 2021 together and admit
that there's a lot of optimism going
into 2022. all right everybody gareth
from the dollop and then also go to
dollpodcast.com because we will be at in
san diego on december 10th at the
observatory and then we have more dates
we'll be announcing but we will also be
going to australia
in new zealand or in just australia
in the spring
so get ready for that um and three two
go get back
1765.
year of our lord jesus christ
stephen burrows was born in
did i do the theme song
did you do no we didn't do the theme
song
we can't do too bad aaron is i don't
know if aaron helps at all aaron's been
sleeping the whole time and called it
quote what if aaron
you both present sick arguments no sleep
don't hippo
hip-hop action part
hi gabby no i sit down my friend
and we're back exhausted
we we uh flexed our muscles if you're
the whole intro song yeah
i do say when those bodybuilders do it
they're getting quite a workout because
they're just standing there like yeah
only thing that's not flexed to the
genitals uh well i could do that all
right and we're back
uh 70-65 already
burroughs uh stephen burroughs was born
in connecticut his father was the
reverend eden burroughs
eden an interesting name for a young
lady eden burrows what are you hungry
for
eat
burrows we're eating burrows
yeah presbyterian minister
who is known for his punishments and
adherence to harsh religion yeah right
of course if you can imagine that in
america yeah it's just
if you write down that a man in the sky
said it will do it yep
in 1772 they moved to hanover new
hampshire where reverend burroughs was
the first minister of a new settlement
uh such a bummer because it's like they
were like
probably like that's right and we'll
probably share amongst each other and
what we were talking about oh hold on a
second this guy's got something to say
yeah so it's the frontier at that time
land has to be cleared for housing and
to grow food so so life's tough yeah
right um one summer three of stephen's
younger sisters died of smallpox within
six days oh my god
that's just how it was yeah i mean i
know that we are like we were like a
terr we were and are but we were so
barbaric and crazy but death really was
just such a different part of existence
it was endless you just couldn't i mean
so you were dealing with like grief on
like in an assaultive fashion
well your whole family's dead
you want some supper no i'm just gonna
go outside and work on the land all
right
i'm dying
tonight okay
uh everyone around you we will cover you
with dirt
well we're all planning on dying
tomorrow so uh i forgot your name man
doesn't matter
stephen was a very difficult child he
said he was quote the terror of the
people where i lived and all were in
declaring that stephen burroughs was the
worst boy in town
who could get him well up to the
worsties who could get him whipped were
most worthy of esteem so oh so normally
yeah i mean like regular boys we'd
obviously just be steaming them yeah but
he would get a weapon oh he would but uh
normally would you hold the boys you
know much like how you make the uh
frothy milk we would just quickly hold
the boys in a little mug
there you go
now you no longer swear in public
charlie but not him he got the beaten
we'll just steam the boys
uh
he enjoyed playing pranks on what is
steve the boys esteem
okay so not steam
aaron if we can uh yep grace is fun riff
thank you
glad i learned he enjoyed playing pranks
on neighbors including upsetting
outhouses
yeah upsetting knocking over outhouses
god i mean just i mean porta-potties are
terrible i mean i saw that happen to a a
kid it's i saw in brown deer park
growing up a guy get a poor and it was
what did they do it on did it land on
the door side no the one i saw
on the door side that's just like
honestly if you had a knife in there you
would be like i just cut your own throat
i don't deserve to live
um
and also stealing watermelons from
gardens which was apparently a very
common thing at the time sure stealing
water he was a water felon
[Music]
what a fun time it was yeah um so young
young steven uh was into this and one
neighbor's patch
he continuously
going on continuously targeted okay so
frustrated the neighbor waited one night
hiding with a club to catch the thief
and beat him jesus christ this is what
you do takes watermelon it's just fine
find a 10 year old and be yeah just like
where you where are you going chuck i'm
going to sleep out in the patch tonight
and if i find this little culprit beat
the [ __ ] out of this club i'm 41.
so steven saw him okay and so then he
went to the neighbor's son and said he
had seen the thief in their patch
oh the kid of the guy who's hiding great
so the son goes to investigate quote the
old man supposing this to be the thief
rushed from his hiding place and
attacked his son with his club
and severely handled the poor fellow
before he found out his mistake the son
supposing the thief was beating him bald
out to his father who ex who expected
was at the house father murder father
murder dad lives around here too huh so
you're doing it right in your
neighborhood i'd love it if your dad
came out here yeah that's right he
probably looks a little like me because
you got my shoulder and my you're very
simple
you took my boy's jacket you took my
boy's jacket and all of his clothes
you took my boy's shoes you're like you
the nerve to steal my watermelons and
take all my boys clothes you i'm gonna
beat the bad out of you
daddy you said that's so you got a voice
box in my kid's coat that makes it sound
like you're him despicable it's me
yes
jeremiah jr
i'm your son oh my god i'm dying where
did all the watermelons go you crushed
my orbital bones i know but a lot of the
melons are missing
damn it my obese i'm going to lay down
on these leaves real quick and see if i
can find some of them i'm going to bleed
out
hold on hold on he might still be here
boy quiet
i'm going to go see well here's one
my blood will nourish the water all
right i'm not spice don't make me
look i'm just another
child here since dying
put some of these leaves over you
see you later do you remember my name uh
yes of course
shh
don't talk what is it don't talk
what's my name try to die what's my name
jeremiah german
germany germany yeah
okay it's close there you go
that was sad
it's not okay what just happened
but it's what happened it's what
happened
uh so when he was 14 stephen tried to
run away and joined the revolutionary
army fester
he joined an artillery company
but then his dad found out and came and
got him discharged
and then that same regiment came through
town six weeks later and stephen tried
again and this time he equipped himself
the way he thought a soldier would quote
i took a bed blanket and tied it full of
clothes and provisions
my provisions consisted of bread and
cheeses that being the only kind which
was ready cooked all this baggage
together with an old musket belonging to
my father powder horn filled with powder
30 balls my appearance in camp in this
ludicrous plight was an object of
universal curiosity and amusement
so he just
packed a gun and a picnic and was like
i'm in the army
yeah he dressed himself he
he lo he looks like a crazy person right
and they and they were like this kid is
a child and he's crazy yeah well they
they still took him because right they
were like
he's got really good cheese he has arms
and eyes so i guess we can use him oh he
can stab
so yeah he convinced the listening
officer to let him enlist on the
agreement that he would not
discharge him if his father came to take
him back there's just one thing if my
stupid dad comes and says i'm not
allowed to be in the army you gotta tell
him to go f himself i mean he's 14. yeah
so uh
the officer agreed but when reverend
when the reverend came he immediately
discharged damn it you said you promised
me uh then stephen give me back my brie
then stephen enlisted again
okay this time with a different
enlisting officer and when his father
came my god the enlisting officer
refused to discharge him unless stephen
agreed to it and he was like no
uh and he refused so his dad's like damn
it
well
it's quite a conundrum well my boy's in
the army now
so the reverend burroughs had to write a
letter to general george washington wow
requesting uh steven's release he
described steven's previous attempts
said he believed the cause in the cause
of america
and said he was washington's servant and
concluded with a ps quote
during the time my son was in the army
he never passed muster nor drew any
bounty or clothing and so steven was
released by george washington wow wow
had to go to the top man
go to the head honcho the president's
like yeah this teenager shouldn't be in
the army come on i've got other stuff
at 16 stephen entered dartmouth college
and uh kept constantly pulling pranks
which chad was like get him out of here
i wish i couldn't find what the pranks
were but
back then kept the school and myself in
a constant upper so you said everyone
was enjoying it okay right so probably a
lot of outhouse stuff yeah a lot of on
putting a watermelon in an outhouse
right yep
stephen thought he had problems at
dartmouth because he did not dress in
the correct manner his shows and clues
were clothes were worn
he was also failing several classes okay
he's pranking a lot so yeah but he
thought he was being unfairly targeted
sure okay sure quote on one hand i was
excited invited and flattered to gratify
those who were fond of amusement
on the other hand i was watched with the
scrutinizing eye of jealousy for
misconduct and readiness to censor
censure me
that would be thought innocent in others
so he's saying i went through that i
complete that's what happened but he's a
prankster yeah no i i'm saying i
understand i like i i know why it had i
was like yeah because you [ __ ] toyed
around a lot watching you yeah yeah yeah
that's what happened yes but i i
definitely felt that i would be like
morning and they'd be like go to the
principal's office i'd be like but i oh
yeah
um
so two years in he was accused of
stealing money and expelled from
dartmouth okay so he leaves new
hampshire for a newburyport
massachusetts where he joined the crew
of a privateer right so he's going to be
a pirate a legal pirate it's just
amazing for your life to be like army
student pirate i know he's like [ __ ]
18 or something yeah i guess i'll just
be a pirate like you're just like going
places like what do you do here i'll be
a pirate okay
so after getting some tips from an old
medicine man he became the ship's doctor
so
remember um this the brain's up here
genitals are here these are feet
and then this is elderberry it's pretty
much good for everything and if anyone
says they don't like the smell use
lavender yeah okay okay so i'm a doctor
now you're not only a doctor you're one
of the best doctors and a surgeon
yes i get to cut people open and take
stuff out absolutely now just remember
this area is full of icky guts oh yeah
yeah you should be able to figure that
out long one's in the stomach did they
do the same thing pretty much right it's
either all blood or processing or air
yeah great so pretty much whatever oh i
love being a doctor you're one of the
best i've ever seen thank you here's a
sword for incisions okay all right and a
gun okay for any uh time yes you need it
i have to shoot a knee off or whatever
shoot someone's knee apart yeah to help
there i'm gonna love this absolutely
yeah god i'm gonna miss you i'm gonna
miss you no
you're gonna die now yeah
okay damn it wow what a curveball
so yeah so he is the ship's doctor quote
after obtaining the assistant i have a
pamphlet i'm the doctor
after obtaining the assistant's advice
and direction of an old practitioner in
physic together with mass
together with marx set on each parcel of
medicine i thought myself tolerably well
qualified to perform the office of
physic on birth can't believe he is just
now a doctor i mean i know that we've
talked about it before but it's known
how do you i it's okay how do you feel
comfortable being considered
well you don't because did you ever
when you had to get a job early on you
were just like tempting or whatever did
you ever say
oh yeah i know xl and then you get the
job and you're like [ __ ] i don't know
actually yeah i guess i've been i mean
so it's never the same thing but it's
not because it's like someone's life i
know but that life doesn't matter back
then i don't know if that's true i mean
odds are a doctor's not doing [ __ ] and i
can't guarantee you the person with the
disease isn't like anyone they're
probably who knows the most yeah but the
guy who knew the most was like hey let's
put beetles in your eyes right i guess i
guess it's almost like
it's almost like if you watch cnn you
know you know less so it's like that i
guess
it's like being trained medically back
then
you it is detrimental to being able to
figure stuff out yeah because you're
like maybe i should cut that out and
they're like cut it out just put your
mouth in there and chew on it
treat it like a dog toy
so the first week on the ship he had
terrible seasickness and
uh and when he got better he immediately
started pulling pranks
so he's okay so we've got c patch adams
this led to the captain accusing him of
stealing wine and giving it to the cream
i know he's a frank he's i don't know
what a prank sir i broke into a bank i'm
a prankie i broke into the liquor cabin
and stole the liquor and drank it i'm a
prankster
called a bit of a jokey
uh
so steven denies it but he uh was kicked
in the head and put in the ship's jail
well you know what we do to you now you
go to jail after a head kick
you know the punishment
keep doing that you'll get kicked in
that twice who wants to boot him oh i do
there we are
back in massachusetts so the ship goes
back to massachusetts he he leaves the
ship and he looks for another ship to
get on as a doctor as a doctor
but before he could he was arrested
several members of his crew were
accusing him of giving wine to a crew
member who had disappeared so there's
clearly wine missing and they've all
decided it's
him
and now they're saying oh you got this
guy drunk or whatever and he fell off
the ship or something but maybe that guy
just took the wine right it's all so we
don't know but it's but people are
saying it's him but speculatively a guy
could have just gotten drunk and then
been like
and also yeah he stephen has also taken
it like it's stephen yes right because
he's a prankster a merry prank i killed
one of them after getting him drunk
such a goof
uh so
they said stephen had quote given him of
wine out of the cabin and that
afterwards i broke open a chest of wine
and handed him the bottles and likewise
broke open a bale of silk and hid one
piece of it so they're saying you know
they stole a little bit but but the guy
died of his own alcohol we don't know
what happened to that guy it doesn't
really go into it but so steven denies
it he just says i don't know but he's
sent to jail okay
now uh he at this point he decides to
give up sea life he's like you know what
boats
it's not working out i'm a good lady
it's hard if you have a
pranking but being enclosed in an area
yeah it's tough because people are like
what's your problem yes you can leave
town
so he get he gets out i don't know he's
released they must not have had enough
on him um and he now decides
that he's gonna become a preacher
but he's not a preacher so he decides to
plagiarize his father's sermons and just
pretend he's a preacher for work
so
in order to be a preacher you had to
have some sort of training but
essentially if you had a bunch of [ __ ]
you could say that was enough yeah you
could you could it's like when i said i
did excel right it's the same right
uh so he auditioned did you lie and say
that you knew him yeah i got a job i got
a job at the writer's guild and then um
after about four weeks they're like hey
can you do this and i was like i gotta
be honest i don't know xl the next day i
was gone you know when i used to valet
cars i would train people once a week
and there were two different times where
dudes showed up and didn't know how to
drive stick and i was like yeah it's
gonna be a real problem and there's no
way that the people who hired you know
that
and also you getting behind the the
wheel of a portion be like
and that's how it would happen someone
would get in the car being like i'm [ __ ]
like their plan was never to be like
once i get there i'll tell the guys
their plan both times was like i'll
figure it out and then i'd just be like
the hell is happening and they'd be like
how do you the clutch is weird i'd be
like that's the break so that's why it's
acting strange for you
uh so
so he starts auditioning for
in different towns to be a preacher and
[ __ ] what audition yeah he would go in
and do like a sermon and they'd be like
oh this guy's pretty good yeah i like
his ceremony pretty good you talk about
the stuff that's not true really well
um and he lands a gig in pelham
massachusetts where he used the name
davis so he's calling himself um stephen
davis davis this is his mother's maiden
name sure
but after a few successful sermons some
people are starting to grow a little
suspicious
i've heard this sermon before
i felt that too a lot of the things he
was saying rang familiar
gosh it just feels like that's not his
sermon
i
do what's known as a common sermon
what does that mean it means it feels
it's super familiar familiar they're
called family they're called familiar
sermons that's by design it's the spirit
of god really that's what's happening
within you i didn't even know that was
pop well i wasn't saying that's all i
just said you were one of the best i've
heard because most of it sounded lifted
yeah i mean it lifted from god right
yeah that's what you're feeling yeah
yeah jesus jesus sorry we judged you
well i don't know if i'll get over it
but okay
very christian
[Laughter]
uh
so
he gets called on
to preach a funeral sermon
so what is i i mean in stand-up terms
this is what he's got a feature gig he's
got a gig at this place he's in a town
he's the town preacher and he is yeah
he's got the gig okay
and um
so someone dies and they're gonna have a
funeral sermon which means it's in a
house
and a private house very crowded
this meant quote
it was in the power of any to look into
my notes
okay
one
who had wandered at my always
being prepared to preach took this
opportunity of looking over my notes and
thought they appeared too old to be
lately written oh so he took he directly
took his father yeah i think he actually
took the page okay and they're like
these are very dog ears yeah right yeah
the date here from a while that's weird
um not signed by you
so people start talking uh-huh and quote
began to grow uneasy with the
apprehension of my preaching sermons not
my own
okay so okay
so he he runs away uh-huh sure so
great great run he runs to rutland but
the angry congregants
come after him wow
i mean this fired up about it's not i
mean
it's still like tech i mean to them
this still would be like the word of you
know a good preacher yeah so
you know i get being like oh those
aren't your words but like the idea to
be like let's kill him
well
yeah i mean
i think it's super offensive to them i
don't know you know
you love him yeah um so they followed
rutland they corner him in a barn sure
and they demand he repay them for two
weeks of sermons he had not made yet oh
so he's he's got he got back he got
signed right to a longer sermon he got
assigned to a seven sermon deal and he's
two sermons short hey listen
like a month ahead uh of sermon that's
highly unorthodox yeah i i gotta i'm
gonna build a new wall oh yeah we all
need a wall i gotta get a hoe i need a
hoe um got a hoe and then
you know yeah
and dirt that's not free yeah okay well
nothing about this is shooting up any
red flags yeah so that's great i'm just
sermon the [ __ ] out of it well that's a
strange
strange thing yeah she's absolutely
serving the show like i'm gonna start
i'm gonna sermon so [ __ ] hard your
eyes
[ __ ] spin as soon as you got that
money it feels like you became a little
that's sweet money in my pocket odd
god's money what's going on yeah
i think it's so much do you know what
tequila is
no
yeah it comes from down south okay what
is it it'll make i call it [ __ ] happy
juice
what is this and you have happy juice my
saying is i'm not responsible for what i
do when i'm on tequila you have because
i i turn it [ __ ] loose your language
is really like i i'm i'm
i've been doing tequila um all morning
you can give us happy juice i got the
money tequila it's so [ __ ] rad it's
your language it's just so you can
without swearing you can get us the
happy juice yeah [ __ ] yeah stop swearing
when you're here
we're all gonna eat the [ __ ] worm you
know what i mean we're gonna eat the
[ __ ] worms stop saying stuff like
that we will eat your worms if they're
happy but the happy juice is what we
have our eyes on
if you can get us the happy juice i'll
pay you but you have to stop swearing
what did you [ __ ] say stop saying
that word
would you stop saying that word
what you [ __ ] stop
do you
listen you son of a [ __ ]
you're really
the smell really what is this happy
juice i'm really what
you ever heard of cabo well i look i
haven't heard of a lot of the things no
what's in the cobble i went down there
and got in a fight with 32 [ __ ] dudes
i mean i feel like this is not great
this is my next sermon [ __ ] okay well
it's pretty good
all right so they haven't cornered a
barn
right forgot about that
and uh they want the money and he's
trapped he's he's in a barn he's up at a
loft and he's got a pitchfork what was
his plan he was like i'll go in that
barn i don't know if he's that way i
can't get out
so he's holy he's standing there after
he's holding a pitch for fork and then
he gives a
furious
sermon this is so stupid this is
so stupid so they've cornered him in the
barn and he now dave he's going to
sermon like he's never sermoned before
and then he realizes i got the sermon in
me i just need
i mean hey that's how it works
it would later be called the sermon on a
heymo
what
he gives a sermon in the barn and
they're like it's the sermon on the hamo
he was on a mountain of hay
uh the beginning uh so one of the quotes
is where i am he cannot come so it's all
about stay [ __ ] away from me and they're
like that's really good what a good
sermon
in it he discussed previous preachers
who had left the town uh
hear ye the voice of the lord which
crieth against the pelhamites for the
anger of the lord soaketh with a furious
indignation against you for the follies
which you committed against the lord and
against his anointed so he's saying like
you guys have a [ __ ] problem right
you keep driving away preachers right
and they're like wait we are and he
references all these previous preachers
who left and uh quote
then said the lord i will give them a
minister like unto themselves
full of all deceit hypocrisy and
duplicity he's the one we need he then
came therefore the lying spirit and
stood before the lord saying
i will go forth and be a spirit in the
mouth of stephen the baronite
and the lord said go
oh so he's just like up there this is
unbelievable stuff
where was this before boy this is
unbelievable stuff he's calling us
[ __ ] and him as [ __ ] he's our
[ __ ] he's one of us so
i hope i just hope one of them was just
like you think we're gonna be able to
sit here and listen to you say something
like that and your fate's gonna change
let's get him it doesn't a long-term
contract no it doesn't work what
happened is a a bystander comes in i was
outside and he's like what are you guys
doing and then he starts questioning the
pelhamites like what the [ __ ] why are
you holding this why are you trying to
kill this guy because he was who are you
oh
because
he was he's a jerk off
okay so right now i think you're the bad
guys and this poor fella up there who's
a preacher i can tell because he's
preaching
he's being pretty brutally honest and
you guys seem like i don't know if this
is the right word but pretty whack
thank god you were standing there by
yourself yeah
well you're welcome what a great
evaluation
[Laughter]
so
he gets away because of this guy
thank god for the bystander yeah um he
stays in massachusetts and at some point
met a con man named phillips and
phillips
claimed he could turn copper into silver
i'm a silver guy
it's so funny that it's kind of like i
love the why wouldn't you just
why why isn't it just iron like how why
is it cop like copper is actually worth
something i'm pretty limited i can only
do copper oh no what am i saying because
people then give them copper never mind
oh okay there was a shortage of hearts
the idea that you
i mean
you know like con people be like i know
where we can make some money downtown
they weren't like you know i'm kind of a
wizard
i'm basically a wizard
okay yeah i can like wizard stuff
well um
there's a shortage of hard currency
because it's right after the
revolutionary war so people are into the
they're like oh alchemy that sounds
[ __ ] awesome like this is a way out
of our plight sure
paper money and banknotes were not
reliable forms of currency and congress
was starting to print paper money
and private banks were making their own
bank currency
so silver is more desirable because
silver's not
it's not the bank's not vouching for it
right and they're like that's better or
the government or whatever
um so stephen and a friend named uh
lysander gave their money to phillips
their coin obviously uh-huh and then he
just left right so really
it takes about five years
sorry i should have said that on the
other side i didn't mention it's a long
long process and all right well i gotta
go to my home to do this and i'll be
right back and my home is
your home
is where you are oh your home my home
you won't come to my home
i'll come to your home no no no that's
not how it works i need to be alone in
order to do it properly do you want your
silver or not guy people can't be around
you when you absolutely not i need to be
in a dark room at a special room i can't
tell you where it is you're driving me
right out of business watch outside
outside no that's probably it's too
close you need to be eight miles away
eight yep otherwise it won't work
believe me i've tried did you be eight
miles away from any person yeah yeah or
no the person who gives me it that's it
the person who gives you the money yeah
yeah i gotta be eight miles away from
them otherwise it won't work this is
science this is science
okay yeah so um but i'll be back but
don't come after me if you come close
during the process which could take a
little while then it won't work then you
waste your money guy don't be an idiot
you're gonna have so much silver it's
gonna spin your top it doesn't sound
great well it's gonna be great trust me
this is what i do i have magic hands and
a machine
i'll see you later buddy bye yep
uh so yeah so the guy leaves and how
long do you think he'll be
another guy who had been taken by
phillips was a counterfeiter named uh
glazer wheeler sure glazer wheeler and
lysander convinces steven to go into
business with wheeler okay leisen under
quote glazer wheeler is a man who can be
depended on
for his honesty to those for whom he
undertakes to work and can
make one silver dollar into three
counterfeits which we'll pass as any so
he's like this guy's really honest he's
a counterfeiter yeah this is the best
counterfeit you can trust this most
honest counterfeiter he's got a job
based on total lies you can get into
business with him it's smart
now steven could not tell the difference
between wheelers counterfeit coins and
the real coins he's like these are
[ __ ] amazing okay but wheeler had
actually never tried them in the real
world okay
so steven took some of the counterfeit
coins and tried them at an apothecary in
springfield and was immediately arrested
so steven just eyeballs these and then
he's like wow they look basically the
same not thinking like someone else
should probably approve or like
it's just a bit of a whim okay and the
apothecary he's like i'm full of
[ __ ] and this is [ __ ]
let me tell you something
do you want a potion to get rid of your
lies
so a member of the pelham congregation
uh became a witness at his trial okay
he said stephen was quote the greatest
villain in the world i've been
everywhere he had come to pelham
under a fictitious name
had there preached when he was unworthy
of the business had endeavored to kill a
number of men in pelham and had cheated
them out of their money objection
uh why because because
that's [ __ ] that's not an objection
that's like an opinion objection
okay what's an objection
when it goes against the the
court's rules like you you would be
objecting to what
the court allows to be i don't think you
should be allowed to say that stuff
no but that's not part of that's just
what you want what you believe not what
the court's rules are
oh all right thank you sir
okay
i'm gonna go on great
with the yeah please continue
why are you
and he had cheated them out
oh sorry
all right sorry sir
so after the pelham guy testifies uh the
judge sent stephen uh to jail and he's
waiting for a trial in the supreme court
i don't know exactly how that worked but
sure
it did make sense but that's this went
to the supreme court there may have been
a hearing before the trial sure yeah
well there's no one living there like
you know right it's probably the only
court that's like
doing this
so he he's in jail waiting for this and
he wrote he writes a satirical book sure
titled the hey mao sermon about
he writes a funny little
slap about what happened when he was
cornered in a barn with a pitchfork yeah
that's the whole thing that happened in
pelham sure he comes clean he
uh
he transcribes his bar barn sermon that
he gave and
puts it on people [ __ ] love it it's
just people were so stupid like those
are great so
he goes into the supreme court trial
like thinking like well i'm [ __ ] hot
[ __ ] like i got this popular book
everyone loves my story
um and he represents himself great
always good as we've said on this show
always right never goes wrong
uh it was described as a very
entertaining performance but the case
against him was too strong and the jury
found him guilty and he got three years
in prison okay
not so funny now all right funny man so
the first night he's in prison he tries
to break out but first night first night
fails okay
um
and soon after he and his cellmate come
up with another escape plan to dig
through the foundation of the cell
chimney
apps
absolutely
chimneys absolutely i mean there had to
be because it was too cold but
there's a chimney in a cell just so you
know there's a fireplace
they need gifts too
uh quote we soon filled our room with
stones and rubbish i labored like
sisyphus in rolling huge stones out of
the chimney way oh my gosh so they're
just taking apart the chimney
and sisyphusing yeah sisyphusing
they uh then come across a really big
stone they can't move at around midnight
that's sisyphusic and then their fuel
ran out for the light so they couldn't
see so they decide when the sun comes
when the sun comes up we'll finish and
get out of here
i mean that didn't go well quote the
jailer came into the room and the hell
are you guys doing it looks like you're
trying to break out
looks like you're in the middle of
and what was the scene pictured to his
view rubbish rocks stones and dirt
filled the room two men almost naked
covered in sweat and dust hey hey
hi we were why are you naked we were
exercising why are you naked uh we were
exercising why is there so much trash in
here uh that's all exercise chimney got
taken apart yeah we went really hard
what exercise are you doing uh why were
you naked doing this thing called the
chimney workout okay
and you got to do it naked why
uh it just was in the book what book can
i see it oh that got burned in the
chimney what where the chimney looks
like it's been taken apart not used and
again i'm gonna ask it again boys where
are the clothes what's the deal uh
they
who
the guys what guys who are the guys the
guys who told us name the guys uh the
chimney boys they had a book they yes
they had a book in their exercise said
they travel around take the chimney
apart naked with a friend that's the
exercise and that's the exercise and
again the trash is for what
it's weird that the trash is the one
you're having the hardest time answering
the naked one you're really throwing the
trash
was in the chimney
nope
it didn't
it was supposed to burn it didn't so
you took the chimney apart
right and then you're fixing it and
working out okay
boy this is
the imagine just walking in there
hey
they got a big stone they can't lift
can you help us how was your night can
you help us lift this stuff get your
clothes off get down here you like
garbage
um
so obviously that's not great uh they
were whipped and then
put into a smaller more tortuous high
security cell oh it's not as funny
anymore but man uh for a minute there
and then they were chained
so okay stevens comes up with another
plant i need to eat the cheese
this is like spaghetti
set fire to the jail we're gonna burn
the whole thing down which would kill
him which is why he was like [ __ ] this
i'm just gonna end oh really yeah okay
uh this is what day three
yes
so the floor is made of boards and
there's cracks between them and then i
guess there's a big space below we need
to shrink ourselves so have you seen
that movie um so he dropped the coals
from his fire through the cracks and the
shavings down below going with it and
other stuff and it starts on fire holy
[ __ ] and then he laid down on his bed
and waited for death any moment now
but the fire didn't come into his cell
like he thought it would instead the
rest of the jail caught on fire so his
his somehow his room is not on fire only
the rest of the jail is burning yeah
so he's like okay you know what maybe
i'll try this is not bad i think maybe
i'll live
it did cause his chain to loosen so
how what it was chained to it like it's
able to
it's all very weird so he now can move
around his cell and then when the fire
was put out they come in and they find
him unchained and they figure oh he
started the fire what but he did start
the fire yeah but it's like their
detective work is crazy
well his chains loose it must have been
him everyone else died you know how fire
works it leaves the guy who started it
he was then stripped and whipped um
after this he was treated terribly and
they stopped giving him food jesus
so his uncle ebenezer comes to course
who else would it be yeah of course
hello i'm from the 1700s
and what's known as a stereotype i'm
being written
so when he goes to see stephen stephen
looks like a skeleton his uncle demands
that he be be put in a better cell and
fed yeah
humans need food yeah we should feed
people he then tried to escape again and
that's it they're like that's it and
they sent him to castle island prison in
boston where he quickly decided to
escape through the chimney
jesus
keep an eye on the chimney would you
guys get rid of the [ __ ] chin i have
a chimney guard there's one guy there
you're a chimney detail
i mean it's amazing to just in a jail be
like and then there's a tunnel out so um
i'm trying to think if there's anything
else i've left out of the tour so again
you can sells lock
open at 7am lock at 10.
there's a chimney there just you just
easy to get up and then you're outside
uh yeah and that's the three hotspot so
great yeah
there you go great is there a ladder in
the chimney
uh well obviously for it to be clean
there has been a chimney so yes there's
a ladder to climb the chimney for it to
be cleaned that goes right outside and
this is a jail you can't leave it no
matter what you do there's a hole out of
it see you later buddy i'm gonna take
off my clothes all right of course we
all are
uh so he uses a nail to scrape away the
bricks and he works for two months and
made a hole large enough to get through
and then waited for a rainy night to
mask the sound okay smart stephen he's
going out through the chimney yeah it's
just hole he's made of course
so this stephen and several other
prisoners a breakout and they were on
the run for three days before they were
caught
i
i it is astounding to me that it is this
i mean
like people break out of jail now like
there's you know so it seems like it
would be a lot easier to get away with
this but they're really struggling
um
so
he gets cod they they they all get
several they get 700 lashings jesus he
tries to escape again and fails
uh he also tried to take over the prison
once that's when you get to that point
where you're like i think i might just
run it
tonight we run it
so at this point he starts to think well
maybe escaping isn't the way to go
okay and he starts bathing well until he
gets released and wow yeah he learned
our boy our boys
uh so he's released in 1788 and then he
goes to stay with his uh uncle ebenezer
in charlton massachusetts this is gonna
be quite a bad time for you i'm gonna
have so much fun do you have a chimney
uncle i'm a wet noodle i only like to
come in and out through chimneys now
it's just something not in my house
you'll go through the trap door
i'm an evil weirdo
hello
jesus i had no idea you like my cane
yeah i'll hit you with it that's how's
that
i'm a dick
i'm ebenezer
my parents said it to me no lifetime of
being a dick when they called me that
yeah no don't yeah me make me a drink no
whoa
well
we're gonna be your own uh a little bit
of your own poison there buddy
my nipples are hot
sorry i've been a while since anyone's
been here
so he marries ebenezer's daughter
he marries his uncle's daughter so he
marries his cousin he marries his cousin
sally davis he runs his cousin
okay
yeah a lot of people einstein that's the
thing einstein married his cousin yeah i
the the list of greats that married
their cousins goes on on einstein
giuliani it goes on
he got a job as a teacher in the local
school
it looks like he's turned a corner and
he's becoming a nice fine man then he
breaks out of the school through the
chimney
but then quote
about six months previous to my marriage
two daughters of d bacon attended my
school
at a certain time the elder
of d bacon's daughters remained with me
in the schoolhouse
a number of circumstances happening to
throw a certain enjoyment full in my
view the temptation was too powerful oh
how i mean how what's how old is this
person no idea
uh i intimated to her that from the
principles of integrity as well as
tenderness to her own welfare i should
keep this business a secret from every
living person oh what a creep so he was
just like i just had a
terribly dirty thought about you but i
shouldn't tell you because i shouldn't
say it out loud and i shouldn't bother
you with my dirty thoughts
so then she and she's just and how i
mean it wasn't just dirty thoughts well
i'm not but that's like seems like what
his move was he was like yeah i just
thought dirty stuff how bad look at your
do you want to hear what it was
yeah and this person is in school yeah
it's one of the students so this is
maybe
let's just say 16. okay that's for
thank you yeah
uh so the girl tells all of her friends
okay after he said don't tell anybody
and soon everyone in the town knows and
he is charged with assault attempt
oh so intent to commit rape
and open gross lewd and lascivious
conduct they got him
as far as the last cap
okay open gross lewd stephen had a
terrible argument quote everything which
took place was in private therefore how
can it be said that open lewdness is
proofed by this testimony it's like
buddy buddy
good i did it behind closed doors okay
okay that's what i was taught to do at
school
i trained as a teacher
i take issue with the fact that it was
gross
but not gross but beautiful
he pleads guilty on this one okay and he
gets three months in prison and lashings
at the public whipping post sure
sure what was his previous crime his
previous crime well why did he get three
years wasn't it for the uh
huh well banknotes for currency oh right
yeah yeah i love that so victimless
crime essentially right right he wasn't
able to pass uh uh
currency victim crime right yeah a lot
less three months yeah it's just a girl
uh
so
he
gets three months in prison and lashings
he next moves to long island where he
got a job teaching
this is like a priest
yeah seriously
he told the community about his crimes
and they still accepted him
well we still think you should teach i
just i just wanna uh sorry
let me start out by saying i didn't [ __ ]
her
wow and quite an opening i i rub some
stuff
um i did a little you know jerky jerky
sure um
didn't like i said i didn't [ __ ]
grammar
it's pretty [ __ ] rad you'll teach
english yeah great okay
all right
this is a society i probably won't do it
again okay
um yeah so they hire him and
even though they know everything about
him
so he so he's a teacher he doesn't think
there's enough books
so he talks to town people and giving
him money
uh which he would use to buy books for a
town library
this is one of the first libraries in
america okay this guy sets it up
um there's a lot of squabbling over the
books between the townspeople and the
elders and sure robert yeah i mean like
it's a weird time where people are like
freaking out of what would be taught or
what wouldn't you know irrationally
could you imagine no i just
[Laughter]
we're going to be fine
so then after this job he goes to
georgia and works as a private tutor
the state is in the middle of a land
speculation craze so people are just
buying a plan and he pretends to be a
land surveyor to get close to this
millionaire uh robert morris
he had helped finance the american
revolution
and morris
trusts stephen sure like he gets in with
him and i love the idea of like acting
like a land surveyor so you're just like
lifting up your glasses like oh yeah
okay that's good excuse me what are you
doing there just surveying the land so
i'm sorry i don't know if you're in the
middle of something but i'm just having
a
quick squint over here just to sort of
okay so it's sort of sloppy yeah okay
you know exactly what i'm looking for a
man with eyes that squint oh i'm looking
at land i'm surveying are you just
what's happening i'm sorry yes i'm
looking for a land surveyor oh yeah
that's what i'm just because that's why
you're squinting
yeah i'm squinting because i'm noticing
a slope so personally like my vision oh
a slope i wouldn't have noticed that
well it's not a profession right there
it's a little sloppy and then over there
you can see that it gets it's a little
bumpy uh-huh just making some notes of
that very impressive 100 kilometers very
bumpy
um yeah i'm swamped right now but i
guess i could work for you i've
kilometers been invented yet um
oh by me i haven't told you about them
yet no
yeah i've got this whole thing
it's gonna work really well and then
we'll change it in this country uh-huh
yep
so yeah it's a that's i'm done surveying
are you a witch no no no no just land
surveyor no promise all right yeah okay
great
so yeah he actually lands very gets in
with this morris guy the more back's so
sore from surveying land oh sorry
morris starts bringing him on projects
he starts making tons of money
um and then the land bubble bursts sure
and morris loses his entire fortune so
much so that he's put in a debtor's
prison oh my gosh
this guy goes from funding helping fund
the american revolution of being like in
a debtor's price so i can turn copper
into silver i guess i shouldn't have
bought georgia
steven
also goes broke
and on top of that a lawyer sold this
house without permission and took the
money and left france oh my god that
guy's the hero that's the hero that's
your favorite person the guy felicia
france after selling someone else's
house
bye i'm gonna have a really good life
[Laughter]
in 1797 he moves back he's got no money
moves back in with his dad
he's working the farm sure
he's 32 he's completely broke okay he
starts writing his memoirs
what would you do i mean obviously it's
time to write the biography no doubt and
he ends up with a 350-page autobiography
okay memoirs of the notorious stephen
burroughs and it's published in 1798 wow
and he keep adding to it over the years
and republishing
sure right yeah uh it's a bestseller
people [ __ ] love it wow so he
takes all the money made from buying
from selling the book
and he starts building a big house on
his father's property which his father
gets mad at he doesn't want a big house
and they get into a big fight
and then stephen leaves with his wife
and kids and
bails on his dad in the house he was
building okay
i mean
okay
and he heads to stupid dad well let me
build a house on his property that's it
we're leaving the house
that's just a crazy thing to do are you
building a house out there no i'm just
putting down foundations that is a house
that's got windows it's a shed you're
building a house god damn it 12 room
shed that's a house you have an [ __ ]
it's a sleeping ship no that's a house
you're not building a house on my land
look at it though it's a house we
probably have to move your house no
we're not moving get out of here
um
so
he moves to stansted i'm gonna build a
house on your property okay [ __ ] you
he moves to the township of stansted
which is now quebec
okay so it goes up there
it's contested land between the u.s and
canada it's not it's like
we're not sure yet land that means
there's no cops and a lot of smuggling
going on there okay
um and steven set up a mill farm
but that's a front okay he was actually
setting up a counterfeiting business
all right great paper money had now
become more accepted and thanks for
printing their own money he's like a
successful author
mm-hmm right mm-hmm
so he but his success is based on
writing about all the bad stuff he did
so he's like richard pryor
yes he's just like oh man i mean i got
some crazy [ __ ] to tell you now yeah
yeah okay
yeah basically okay um uh so
a lot it's basically a lawless land
paper money is now more accepted um and
banks are printing their own every bank
i love them banks have their own money
to me that is the craziest time in
american history it's just amazing and
when you're just like every bank has
their own money yeah
um
stevens made counterfeit money for many
different banks and then his partners
would smuggle it into the u.s okay
he's already a notorious criminal
because of the book and sometimes his
smugglers would get caught and it became
clear they were working for him
and because of his reputation everyone
assumed stephen was the source of all
counterfeit notes in the uk so it's just
basically what happened to him in school
yeah where like any like because of his
track record they just assumed that he's
doing way more than he is totally right
uh the u.s has no extradition treaty
with lower canada so he's safe he can
just keep doing it
this gray area land situation crazy it's
pretty great
um it's like the bermuda triangle yeah
there is a there is a part of
yellowstone that's supposed to be the
same way
let's just go there and open a casino
so he just keeps growing the operation
he opens a second manufacturing uh spot
is students franchising his counterparts
yeah
okay a group of bankers then hire a
sheriff named baron to track down and
arrest stephen so sheriffs were just
like i also work for people who pay me i
think they are still
sure i'll take a break and go hunt your
friend
he raided uh so this guy raids stephen's
farm with 22 armed men in the middle of
the night and caught stephen who was
sleeping in bed sure
baron took him to montreal and there a
judge sends him to jail okay um but he's
released on bail and then he moves his
family to montreal i don't know why he
did that but okay
um he was then arrested again
when one of his men was caught buying a
ton of paper to make notes okay
so uh he's arrested for counterfeiting
and now the judge has it out for him
all right
stephen was charged with two counts of
forgery even though
it wasn't technically illegal to
counterfeit foreign currency in canada
you you can't counter
fit canadian currency but counterfeiting
other characters are totally fine in
canada
different i mean you found the loophole
of lubricant right this judge is like
[ __ ] that yeah the judge
so
it's like the written house judge it yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
stephen escapes before the trial and
canadians they're like whatever they
don't care right okay great
so he goes back to stansted and there's
a smallpox outbreak and he uses his
doctor's experience to help the
neighbors
through smallpox yeah because he was out
of his element yeah completely but
whatever now everyone loves i helped
someone with their knee on a boat once
oh boy
this is crazy
sure is bumpy you're like braille people
i guess slice you open with my magic
doctors put you in fire for 20 seconds
and then pull you out hey my doctor
sword we're going to do what's called
medically searing you oh good yeah just
get a nice little grill uh yeah
then we'll put you in the oven oh no i
think i'm gonna eat you i'm gonna die
yeah baby
so uh
the judge
so this judge now all the people are
all the people are not protecting him
because he helped him so much during the
smallpox thing so everyone around but he
did help yes somehow i don't know like
yeah he did what is he like i don't know
he might he may just help from like
being the only they're there
they're there who would go near people i
mean that happened a lot sure you know
but also smallpox was is an airborne
thing yeah it's terrible yeah so like
that's i mean i get that why you'd be
like you know that seems like a
magnanimous gesture but
i
in that time i'd be like i mean you know
with covid would you be around would you
be there being like it's okay no i'd be
like i'd have my head in the sand like
an ostrich yeah absolutely
um so
so the judge the one who arrested him
before him was out to get him
he is actually loyal to the u.s and
banks
some people think the banks are paying
him off right
it's just never stopped the code has
been cracked and keeps being the same um
all the local magistrates are not on
board with that so they petitioned to
have the judge removed okay and he was
wow
but before he leaves he searches
steven's farm and he confiscates and
and steals money
and even personal possessions so the
judge goes yeah he must have like a
force or something with him
um i that part it just seems so weird to
me but
he is crazy it's crazy from to go from
one moment to be like you're judging the
misdeeds of another and then when that's
over you're like i'm gonna rob that guy
like okay so you probably shouldn't have
been in this elevated position well he
is clearly just working for the banks
yeah right but i mean but it's amazing
to go from that still to just like i'm
going to take from him
i will steal his stuff
him
quote plundered me of all my writings
containing my private correspondence
documents of value and other papers
together with 53 000
and carried the whole into the united
states wow so he takes the counterfeit
money and he's like i'll use it well no
he's not using it i think he's taking it
for the banks oh so
right since he's bought anyway
but with the judge gone he's now able to
expand his business there's no one
really looking over him again his son
his daughter's wife they're all now
working for him uh his daughter sally
signs all the counterfeit notes that's
so cute the whole time men from banks
are harassing him they would come they
would take notes
and then he just set up and print more
so it's just you know a cycle
very similar to our econom economic
system yeah basically
when the bank gilbert and dean printed a
book explain
that i mentioned the bank's name is
gilbert d i thought they were writing
broadway show channels
where show tune bank yeah show money
um i love they had their own money yeah
so
they print a book explaining what to
look for in counterfeit notes and steven
responds by sending them a mocking
letter
pretending he had opened a bank named
shipton bank
and he asked to get good credit at their
bank
saying he would repay them with stock
from his bank
and this is a joke it's a joke there's
no bank he doesn't have a bank
and everyone knows it is right
and he said that in their paper quote
buckwheat pancakes have been so exactly
counterfeited in new jersey that none
except the officers of the pancake
exchange could distinguish them from the
original i solicit your friendship
gentleman in this important business
he also included a drawing of an
orangutang and the words death or botany
bay hahaha
so he's just completely really just
botany bay meaning you know you're going
to send me transportation to
australia right um he's just completely
[ __ ] with it right it's very i mean
so i mean he's like he's onioning them
yes right
it's funny because normally like humor
in that when you read quotes and humor
none of it makes sense the pancake thing
is i'm like i get it i get what he's
going for i get it yeah and people love
this [ __ ] right yeah yeah they're making
fake buckwheat pancakes you know yeah um
in 1808 the laws new laws were created
to crack down on counterfeiting in
america and canada finally so his
network shrinks and in 1810 as the laws
are coming into place he asked the
governor of lower canada for clemency
and the way he does this is he writes a
letter with all of his crimes in them
and
said since the new laws he'd given
everything up
and burned all of his notes
and destroyed all the machinery
and then he sends that letter off
didn't go as planned he was then
arrested because of all the crimes
yeah he did wow
i got your letter and we're gonna put
you in jail so uh
uh
the letter he wrote the governor was
used as a confession at his trial under
the new law i was thinking like you
don't need to write everything you don't
you know he wrote like 50 yeah
um he was sentenced to transportation to
botany bay wow
yeah
what
predicted it
he did that in a note of absurdity yeah
and now they're like you're going there
um but after six months in jail quote
to do the americans a favor he was
pardoned on giving heavy bonds for his
future good conduct so i don't really
understand what happened here but
um
it was part of a general pardon
to mark the 50th year of the king's
reign
so the king
as like a good fighter just let a
clean the record of a bunch of americans
sure of which parties which yeah which
was one okay so i don't know why that's
a thing for the 50th year but okay it is
sure
very lucky yeah very long when you hear
that you're like wait what they're like
so the king's just sort of picking some
people and um i guess you're free now
king just i don't know it's the 50-year
anniversary so
there you go you and seven psychos you
get to go do whatever you want again
that's so weird because the king um so
the war of 1812 breaks out um fighting
is happening in that part of canada
where
his mill farm is
and he started working for the british
royal authorities as a spy
he said he was promised quote a handsome
provision for the performance of these
services
and he borrows money to fund his secret
little missions that he's doing
uh but then
he sent his son on the missions in his
place
so he really just he his son finally
he's a racket it's so crazy everything
has to be everything
nothing is straight up right
so his son gathers all this information
and uh then they make a report and he
turns it
over to the officials
but it turns out the officials
don't have no one knows about this deal
for him being a spy
at all they're like what are you talking
about and because it's hard it's a hard
position when you're a spy
trying to let people know that you're
you know what i mean like yeah you're
giving up your actual identity
i'm sitting here as a shh
the king
[Music]
so i think that they think he's conning
them of course because of his rep and
he's so he's arrested and put in jail
but in the end he gets released without
try being tried right
but he said i mean he's considered a
prankster so they're like you're
pranking us uh but he still keeps up his
part of the bargain which is to stop
counterfeiting except for pancakes
except for pancakes
he lost his farm and land and shipped in
and stands dead
over contested land rights so then he
moves with his family to troy rivera's
where
his son lives
and is working as a choir boy uh boy for
the chief justice he had been there
since he was arrested for counterfeiting
in vermont so his son he's working as a
choir boy for the chief justice oh sorry
choreboy oh my god i was like what
um even though you're a one-man choir
um okay so you're working
that's a great autocorrect yeah a
sure choirboy
so he went he went
along
that's good that's good little more now
yes it was sonic gone to vermont got
arrested for coming all these candles
out
not like that we've got the thick don't
lick them no no no no no no don't do the
thing you did before the thing you did
before
better
um so yeah sonic gone to vermont got
caught counterfeiting and then ends up
working for this guy so they all move
there where he is
he's broke again sure right yeah he's
following the success of the chore boy
and he gets work as
a school teacher
what
he began to lead a respectable life sure
he converts to catholicism oh that's one
step and gets involved in the church
finally they're moral some don't believe
it they think he's you know using this
kind of another one of his jokes
but it looks like it's on the up and up
okay and he ends up becoming a school
superintendent superintendent sure
he's respected by people in the town
people would always come to see him
because he's famous right
one wrote quote his room was hung around
with copies of originals of the
masterpieces of some of the
distinguished painters of christian life
and suffering
and everything about him indicated very
convincingly the genuineness of his
repentance and reformation
okay so he found religion
i'm dubious no he did really yeah
he published a new book in 1836 called a
view of practical justice as
administered in lower canada displayed
in a memorial addressed to his
excellency the earl of gosford is that
the title that's the title what is it
again a view of practical justice as
administered in lower canada displayed
in a memorial address to his excellency
in the earlier what happened the first
time that someone had a title like that
was like kind of like a night to
remember they were like um
but what is it
what night
can you tell us what night it was
let's put the exact date and tell us why
do you remember it so tell us the night
that it happened and why we should
remember it the title should really be
more like the first page
it's the opener
uh so in this he
uh printed his letters to the british
government where he um
is trying to regain his lost land
and money so he's like asking them you
know right
a quote on the cover page reads truth is
great and will prevail it did not
prevail okay yeah it was completely
unsuccessful and he died in 1840 at the
age of 75. [ __ ]
he's considered americans like first
criminal
really yeah
and that that's crazy so and that's why
he was able to get away
with
i mean
it's almost like we've talked about it
before like where it's the first time
something happens
but
people can't process like the first time
you get conned nobody's conned anyone
yeah so like when you're a high level
liar
or con person like and moving to a no
law zone yeah like it's all
bizarre man
i would have been fleeced in this time
uh
research by this was done by camilla
galaz i'm sure i said her name wrong um
sources
uh
susanna ashton a corrupt medium stephen
burrows and the bridge hampton uh
yeah uh a stephen burrow's own book
uh he had oh four uh larry a kabula a
counterfeit identity the torah slice
life of stephen burrows and also
uh kabul also wrote bring me the head of
stephen burrows
ernest ferguson the entertaining saga of
the worst crook in colonial america
that's on
smithsonian magazine
uh
john garcia he hath ceased to be a
citizen
sure um
christopher jones
praying upon truth the memoirs of
stephen burrows and the also
my shitty nephew by ebenezer clark my
[ __ ] nephew
um
j i little american center slash
canadian saint the further adventures of
the notorious stephen burrows
stephen mim the alchemy of the self
stephen burrows of and the counterfeit a
lot of people wrote about this guy and
the counterfeit economy of the early
republic
and then the new england historical
society stephen burroughs counterfeiter
and uh daniel williams in self-defense
author and authority of the memoirs of
stephen burrows
wow our buddy our buddy i mean he's a
[ __ ] king more like stephen barros
what nothing go ahead
seems like
um
yeah
we have a better banking system now
do we no
right
there we go there's that there's that
knowing there's that knowing anthony
sipp it's yeah
good is that a quote yeah everything's
good it's yeah good
good feel good
great i feel great man great
i feel great great hot
great okay well this is um someone asked
me why uh i always say things are bad
and offers no solutions but no one's
hearing the solutions it's called direct
action you guys
here we go see i told you i could turn
his crank a little bit well
like stop saying i don't say anything i
i keep saying we need to go out in the
streets and [ __ ] shut everything down
and people go what about a little
electoral politics isn't going to help
you cop no sex you can tell it is
amazing it is
where i'm not going to spin nope not
going to do it it's just amazing that uh
yeah that that it's just like people the
idea of still being caught up in like
the
solution living inside of our government
or right next to it and doing it through
that
to fix things is just
we see the hunger games wedding the
pelosi hunger games wedding oh yeah
um
you know biden
in his campaign he said he's gonna stop
offshore drilling and today
they are auctioning off like 350 [ __ ]
drill sites so
and this is you know what
a day after cop26 ended
like it's not going to be done through
electoral politics we have to shut
everything down but people have to go
out in the streets and just say yeah
okay it starts stuff it feels like
in
that the general
people are reaching points where things
are becoming so terrible that there's
nothing you can do other than be like
[ __ ] off yeah like it's happening a lot
of obviously in a lot of companies where
yeah workers are just like
you know you can't
even
greed
ca
at some point will stop beating
desperation like people when you when
people have nothing
or are looking
or are just [ __ ] done
that's how you uproot stuff yeah and
people are done and through yeah i mean
i don't even know which thread you would
start pulling first in order to change
it honestly every time i'm like
government then i'm like banks
you know so
uh anyway we signed cars yeah we signed
uh
cars one eight seven seven we signed
cars for kids all right thank you god
bless everyone tata gobble gobble happy
turkey day
you